hey 42 here Japan is probably the most
health-conscious country in the world
they have the highest life expectancy
the most centenarians per capita and
they eat so much fish as a country Japan
has gone to extraordinary lengths to
maintain its reputation as the world's
healthiest place for instance the vast
majority of Japanese companies make
their employees do mandatory exercise
for half an hour every morning before
they sit down to work studies show that
this not only helps physical fitness but
also keeps employees mentally sound and
improves productivity but Japan doesn't
have a health craze like Los Angeles per
se you won't find any seaweed and dust
to diet fads here a healthy lifestyle is
just a deep-rooted part of the Japanese
culture but with the influx of Western
fast food Japan's healthy outlook is
showing signs of crumbling under a
mountain of melty plastic cheese and in
a country where only 3% of the
population are overweight which is tiny
compared to Australia at 60% those few
people who are obese tend to stick out
like a sore thumb it's becoming a major
problem because so few Japanese are
overweight there's a lot of prejudice
towards the not so small minority
it's common for overweight individuals
to be bullied in the workplace an even
cast out of their family just for
packing a few extra pounds
normally government combat obesity with
hopeless advertising campaigns and even
taxing junk food but Japan went the
extra mile and simply made it illegal to
be fat in 2008 Japan's lawmakers passed
a law called Metabo law which is short
for metabolic syndrome you may be
watching this thinking it's happened
Japan has finally lost it but the Metabo
law isn't as extreme as it seems you
won't be locked up just for being
overweight so then what is the
punishment for eating too many
cheeseburgers seppuku no it's a bit more
complicated than that
under the Metabo law every Japanese
citizen between the age of 42
seventy-five years old that's 44 percent
of the population has to have a
mandatory check of their waistline every
year the government states that the
legal maximum waist circumference for
men is thirty five point four inches
whereas for women it's only thirty one
point five inches so this law is
basically a must-have slap in the face
to guys who like curvy women to put
these insanely restrictive numbers into
perspective in Japan is considered gross
and illegal to have a waist over 35
inches as a male whereas the average
male waist size in America is 40 inches
if during their annual checkup a citizen
is found to have larger waistline than
the government imposed limit they are
required by law to attend regular
counseling sessions because you know
according to Japan if you're fat it must
be because you're mentally unstable of
course and on top of that you have to
regularly consult a dietitian to discuss
dietary options whilst the penalty for
individuals focuses on rehabilitation
there are heavy fines for companies that
don't follow the government guidelines
under Metabo law companies are required
to monitor the waist lines and general
health of all their employees and
encourage regular exercise in a healthy
lifestyle if a company is found to have
employees with illegal waist lines they
must pay heavy fines to the government
until everyone in their business has
shed their excess baggage
in fact fines for companies can be as
high as 19 million dollars just because
someone in the office is a greedy booger
to avoid these fines companies have
resorted to handing out so-called and
the Tabo towels to all our employees
which is a towel with a built-in tape
measure so employees can check their
waistline when they step out of the
shower each morning those crazy Japanese
may seem well crazy but this
controversial law has worked obesity
rates have dropped significantly since
its inception in 2008 well-done Japan
but seriously guys you didn't even have
an obesity problem in the
first place thanks for watching do you
ever hear a noise not to bump in the
night per se but a home you'll probably
pass by anything nothing more about it
but this is the smallest town in all of
America with a grand population of just
one